DeMarcus is with us in Chicago hey
DeMarcus how are you I'm gonna find Dave
how about yourself
better than I deserve sir how can I help
right now um right now I am 21 years old
my fiancee right now is carrying our
child see seven months pregnant you know
I grew up in a very rural neighborhood
and right now me and my fiancee I have
no debt and we're looking to keep it
like that and right now I'm trying to
find some type of guidance or some type
of way I can financially be set up for
my child because I refuse to how much I
live the life that I've done well living
like that I've lived as a child so I was
wondering was there any steps that I can
take as far as financial financial arm
you know peace or some type of way that
I can make sure my child has a very good
life good man it's a good question from
a good guy um so what do you do for a
living right now I work in the home
steel factory okay and what's your
income right now I make it roughly um 35
years okay what about her does she work
outside the home I'm CB right now I
thought I'd you know to take a leave off
um take work off you know um for the
pregnancy so when she goes back to work
after baby's home and I'm long think
about how much $15,000 12 a fifty-year
Wow you know yeah 50 a year with with
the bulk of us okay all right well the
good news is that there's two sides to
the equation not 16 there's the income
side the outgo side and we work on both
of those working on the income side is
working on your long term career and
that's saying I'm 21 years old when I'm
41 what do I want to be doing with my
career and what will I be making because
that's part of the answer to the
question of how do I take care of my kid
right yes okay and then the other part
of the equation is how do we take care
of the outgo side and there's really
only three or four things and then a lot
of complication within those three
four things that you need to do and I'll
help you do that okay the first one is
we're gonna get on a written budget I'm
making every dollar behave every dollar
has an assignment and you can use the
app that is free for your phone or your
computer or both called every dollar
it's free we built it and it takes about
ten minutes to set up your budget you
and your fiancee can go over it together
okay
the second thing is then that you avoid
debt like it was trying to kill your
family because it is all of the data
that we have from millionaires people
that start with nothing a lot of them
started very poor and became
millionaires they avoided debt because
when you give other people your money in
the form of car payments student loan
payments mastercard payments you you
don't have the money anymore and if you
give it to them and you don't have it
anymore you can't use it to become
wealthy with called investing right new
thing you have to stay out of debt you
have to stay on a plan we're gonna save
and invest our first savings element is
to build an emergency fund a rainy day
fund because as you quickly find with
little kids and young marriages you you
you you know sometimes it rains and you
need an umbrella right now currently
have 25 projects so far in my emergency
boys good you're moving in the right
direction then okay and then let me
think here you know you start your
investing you always want to have giving
be part of your equation for me when I
was your age it wasn't long after that
that we had our first kid in my early
20s Denise who's now in her 30s a big
part of me being able to provide for my
family was I got really really really
plugged into a great church and my walk
with God changed the man that I am and
made me into a better daddy and a better
husband than I would have been otherwise
and so I'll put that on my list of
suggestions for you to look at because
it you know it gets it it teaches you
the character parts the value system
parts of
being a great dad so you said fiance and
seven months pregnant when's the wedding
yeah we're not going to know how to win
from all the money there's going to be
four for our bank account you know we're
not flashing
you know either weddings when's the
wedding now when when we're financially
able to okay all right now we don't have
a certain time for that all right again
you made the mistake of asking my
suggestions so I'm going to give them
the know here's what I would do if I
woke up in your shoes you get to do
whatever you want you're a grown man
okay right but if I woke up in your
shoes I would get married and I would
have the reset now immediately and I
would have the reception sometime later
and we'll not want to have the money for
a big party and celebrate the marriage
later and because you've already made
all those other decisions here's why I
would do that there's a couple of
reasons I would do that but here's why
there's a thing in research on families
that says this if you marry before
having a child and you have that child
after age 20 and you graduate from high
school you have an almost 0% chance of
the child being raised in poverty
isn't that interesting 97 percent who
follow that success sequence earn a high
school diploma work and marry before
having children will not be poor as they
enter their 30s and that's called the
success sequence which is married have a
kid be working get married have a kid
start your life and you have the
opportunity to put that in the right
order I don't know that it matters a
whole lot today in your situation but if
I were in your shoes I would go with
that 97% statistic I think it's a big
deal only four percent of homes with a
married mother and father are on food
stamps but 21 percent of people who live
together are that's some interesting
statistics okay I don't think you're
heading there but you called and asked
me if I woke up in your shoes at 21 so
I'm giving you more advice than just
money advice and you probably got more
than you bargained for but anyway the
last thing I want to do is I want to
give the child I'm gonna give the baby a
gift and that's I'm gonna put it's mommy
and daddy through Financial Peace
University I want you guys to go through
our class on how to handle money and
I'll show you all of those 93 little
details and show you exactly what to do
so you work on being the man that it
sounds like you already are a good man
worried about and being noble and
concerned about your child and being a
good husband and work on your spiritual
life and work on your career and get
your income up over time and I'll show
you how to become wealthy and completely
change your family tree and avoid a lot
of the pitfalls and potholes that are
out there Financial Peace University is
a one-year membership you go to a local
group and take nine different lessons
and the whole thing is also accessible
online oh and that gives you every
dollar plus which is connectivity to
your bank for a year as well so you hold
on all of that as my gift to your baby
that's my opinion you asked it and I'm
an expert on my opinion this is the Dave
Ramsey show